this
takes me into what pineapple express did
that's the part where you brought up and
said pat this entire time people are
thinking we have to rely on somebody to
do something this is a group of
civilians that are like listen dude we
don't care we're not waiting on you
we're going to go out there and do this
right you want to unpack what happened
with those guys so the listeners can
kind of yeah so for people that don't
know there's a bunch of ex-veterans
they're uh they're no longer active duty
or the ones that are active duty refused
to
identify themselves obviously because
they pretty much broke international
treaties and they they committed an act
of war by invading uh a sovereign
country but really these are guys that
were on uh that did multiple tours in
afghanistan these are special forces
guys that got sick and tired of waiting
for the government to get their allies
and people who helped them people who
helped save their life their lives
translators particularly in their
families uh out of harm's way so they
just went in they said screw it we're
not waiting for clearance i mean this is
like a 1980s like like arnold
schwarzenegger movie this is like
predator this is like hardcore old
school america is the best
movie stuff here but these are real guys
who went in and they saved between 500
and a thousand people they got them
across the borders out of afghanistan
and and uh we'll never know who they are
because obviously they're they're
technically war criminals now but these
guys are heroes we know how some of them
are because they talked about it a
couple of them a couple of them came out
and flooded they talked about it and tim
kennedy apparently was very uh very very
um big in organizing it and and uh he's
a style yeah that guy's a frickin stud
you know tim is a special guy
do you have opinions on that or did you
there's a lot going on i think um
look anyone
as an american or even as a citizen of
the world should just look at this and
just be like there's a complete [ __ ]
show but what did we expect it's almost
like we don't learn any lessons look
back in history what the hell happened
in vietnam america you can get into a
war very easily but i think we realize
it's very hard to get out of a war it's
very ugly to get out of a war i think
something that we need to recognize is
what's the lesson here we can be
anti-terrorist badass mother suckers and
get in and take care of business but we
cannot
build nations we're not nation builders
we can't go into goddamn middle of the
middle east and think that they're going
to come to around our way of thinking it
didn't happen in iraq it's definitely
never happened in iran it's not
happening in afghanistan
let's learn our lesson so the next time
that something happens here
god forbid a 9 11 happens we don't rush
to judgment 30 days later and declare
war in afghanistan when like you said
before we're fighting at the al qaeda
but al qaeda was our friends in a
different war and now we're fighting the
taliban but now we're making peace with
the taliban because they're fighting
isis k who's like basically the delta
variant of isis
and it's like we can't figure this out
and we never will
we don't understand that way of the
world the government though like it's
from the inside i mean obviously you
have what was his name sheller he goes
online and he starts speaking out and
this guy's getting hit pretty hard
internally
so i think you know obviously it starts
from the inside like when pat you like
you talked about like we can't really do
anything about this this starts inside
we don't know if there's coups involved
in in our own freaking government all
the different branches can you say
inside inside america absolutely you're
telling me that they don't have like
there's drama within our own government
clearly with our own military clearly
there's different special interests
because how in the hell does this take
place
yeah this is the whole if it's even
within our government let me let me let
me ask you this so you just you just
made a point about hey we can never
solve this and this is problem's always
going to be here it's always been there
it's not
all the stuff that you said okay fine
yes but that's not that's not the
challenge right now that we didn't get
here because nobody agreed on leaving
the left and the right and the middle
everybody said we gotta leave there
isn't anybody that's disagreeing on
staying except for the
five to ten percent of the veterans who
are actually there who saw what happened
who have emotional affinity to the
people there that want to see their
lives change and they feel like maybe
we're a generation away except from the
true believers 80 to 90 percent of
america all agrees on let's bring the
troops back fine but here's a question
for you here's a question for you okay
so uh what is the right way you're at a
club okay
there's a shooting you're at a club
there's a shooting you hear a shot goes
out what's the right way to leave the
club
what do you look for when you leave the
the nearest exit the nearest exit and
you leave okay let me ask you a question
do you look for your friends or do you
look i'm just gonna run they're gonna
fight they're gonna find around a way to
run as well i'd like to think i grabbed
my friends who are around me okay now
let me ask you a question here but if
you're if you're with your buddies and
they're all athletes you're probably
like dude you're gonna find a way out
dude let's go guys fellas let's get the
hell out of here right in the spur of
the moment are you thinking where's jim
where's where's bob let me flip it like
you know
let me flip it let me flip it on you let
me flip it on you you're at them all
with your two kids
there's a there's a fire you hear a shot
what's the first thing you're thinking
about grabbing kids grab your kids and
then you leave right okay great
you're in your house there's a fire
you got two cats you got a dog and you
got two kids okay fire breaks out one of
the uh propane blows up and fires
everywhere what are you doing before you
leave the house trying to stop the fire
trying to stop the fire but you're
trying to get everybody out first right
is it fair to say that common sense says
what we got to get the hell out right
there is no common sense that says don't
get out so the problem isn't we got to
get out the problem is how do we get out
of here so you have to prioritize on how
you get out by the way here's a question
for you
if you see if you're sitting in a room
you know shit's about to go down what's
the best thing you got to do if you know
the the enemy right there is about to do
something crazy what's the best way for
you to react
let's just say i text you i'm like hey
uh shit's about to go down adam uh phil
gerard in a text
guys uh we have five minutes to get out
of here leaving four
you grab your [ __ ] weapons and make
sure that you have them but but the way
you're gonna leave you're gonna be like
guys let's not overreact just like just
slow chill out just like okay so the way
we're going to do it is you're going to
say i'm going to go to the bathroom and
then gerard's going to be like you know
what i got to call let me call my girl
yeah and then gradually i'm like slowly
so slowly you go out you're not going
dude like that's how we left because we
left like that so the whole point isn't
let's leave we know we need to leave the
mission damn right we know we need to
leave the damn mall how we left so okay
so now
uh
leaving afghanistan for dummies okay
let's read that book we're leaving
afghanistan for dummies okay let's let's
somebody should publish that book well
step number one you got 85 billion
dollars of equipment yeah
okay um civilians got to go first so
first of all we need the equipment
civilians got to go first those
translators those interpreters who
helped us out gotta go first then what
goes next
in my opinion the troops go last i agree
with you okay but i don't know why we
put out the troops and we're like oh by
the way but we forgot a hundred thousand
civilians and all our [ __ ] so so thank
you it as backwards but think about how
much of this is just pure
common flipping sound because it's it's
reaction versus response
when you react you do what they freaking
did when you respond that means that
you're more calculated period and they
did not have like number kids like you
have a fire drill yeah like you have
certain protocols systems all that other
crap
where was theirs
where was that list here's the other
part here's the other part if you think
about this okay there's a part that i
don't agree
with the president
saying what we're about to do next too
early here's what i think
i think it's like listen guys i don't
know probably in the next to two to four
years we're gonna try to leave
afghanistan there you go but you leave
in six months but nobody needs to know
that you don't as a
president sit up there yeah here's my
card hey guys we're leaving in the next
week oh [ __ ] they're about to leave in
the next week like look we're gonna try
to go in the next two to four years
we'll see what's going to happen okay
and we'll see what's going to take place
but we are working on it we have a plan
we'll see what will happen then you know
you're about to leave in the next 30
days
there's a part of this that
strategically but it it just validates
whoever is that's in the commander of
chief position president position
they're hacked they have to be
strategic
they have to understand the art of war
they have to understand power
and then the subtle maneuvering you
don't just go and say hey
i don't know i'm just no i mean it's a
bill you said you said it a while ago on
a podcast i believe last time i was here
uh
that the commander-in-chief needs to
have some experience serving in the
military because of what you just said
i mean if they if he had some level of
experience of expertise
he would
actually have to know
the art of war all these things that you
described or or you know how we do it
let's just say you don't okay let's
because we're gonna go in an era where a
guy's gonna be a president like a trump
biden bush let's just say these guys
here's how it works
you're the final vote
but you got a board of six seven you're
one of the votes but you're the
executive chairman when it comes if
you've never served in the military
you're gonna put generals there
uh marines air force army everybody
that's your national security you put
your national security council and right
there the vote is
four
if four in that room say boom go but
it's not one biden doesn't get a chance
to vote neither trump neither any of
these guys yeah you sit there and say
boom let's get out a few things that
that really come to mind from this thing
is the way biden's handled it really
makes me feel like he's not running the
show he's a puppet i'm not supposed to
answer questions i'm not supposed to who
you're the president who's telling you
what to do yeah if anything you should
be standing up with your chest out and
saying like
but it's very obvious and i'm not and
that's not like i'm not trying to knock
biden on this now i'm legitimately
concerned who's calling the shots here
man that's number one absolutely number
two all right is i think it's beyond
obvious now like you said it before what
are we learning from this why why we
can't nation build adam i don't think
they ever intended to i think that they
were there to
to suck millions and millions of dollars
and keep these incredibly high-paying
jobs why do they not care about eight
billion dollars worth worth of ordinance
being left behind because it wasn't
their money they don't care it didn't
come out of their pocket that stuff was
already bought and paid for and in fact
the defense contractors are like let
them have it we got to buy new stuff
absolutely they don't want to win these
wars they just want to keep them going
for as long as possible this thing made
them i don't disagree so much money and
the patriot act right we have the
patriot act we have tsa now they said
they're trying to spin it they're trying
to spin this that we don't need to be
there anymore because we we we hit the
objective it was osama bin laden was the
objective okay well then the patriot act
was there because of bin laden and
al-qaeda and now you're telling us the
taliban have learned their lesson so why
do we still have to go through tsa why
are we still doing all that bs is that
just again and now what does that mean
to me with everything we're doing today
that was the quote-unquote new normal
yeah and that was supposed to go away
but now the patriot act is never going
away right we live in a surveillance
state just like taxes it's never going
away so learn from learn what do you you
to your point adam what can we learn
from this be very careful which freedoms
you give away in in in terms of well i
just want to feel safe because we're
learning right now when the crisis is
over
you're not getting them back it's not
happening let me add to your point you
you've talked and talked used this term
the military industrial complex yep it's
a real thing
this is disgusting to see what's going
on here so something that pat always
says here that we learned anyone who
starts with valuetainment says
treat the company's money like it's your
own do you not say that pat
treat the company's money so if you're
gonna go out and get a hotel you're
gonna get a car rental you're going to
get equipment you're going to get
whatever you're going to treat it like
it's your own and you're not going to
waste some spending save that money
and it's just disgusting to see
how much waste and fraud is going on
there with within government spending
yeah it's disgusting so let's circle
back to the original question what were
they supposed to do with this equipment
if they weren't they're not how are they
getting tanks back how are they getting
bombers back
they see i've never been in the military
but it seems obvious rather than letting
them have it don't you just blow that
[ __ ] up why wouldn't you
explain to me why you wouldn't just
and you know that crazy you need an
enemy
to go back in and create another 10
years exactly scared what you said is
what trump said
but i don't know if you're what trump
said he said here's a plan
first you get the civilians out yes then
you get the interpreters out let's just
say the allies then
you get some of the equipment out then
you blow every unit up you blow it up
because if there's any anything you blow
every base up that we have then we get
the troops that come back up yeah that
was his formula on how to do it so you
were just aligned with trump i'm not i'm
not even making this a a president i'm
aligned with trump i'm allowed to biden
thing like you said
but trump never
wait a minute you're aligned with common
sense sure great awesome that's a first
for me right bingo no it's not here we
got a first for you if if if americans
actually looked at this [ __ ] they're
not from
but rather from common sense we many
people would be on the same side i agree
but my point is this
forget about trump forget about biden
forget about bush forget obama because
they're all guilty and they're all we're
involved in this war i mean starting
from bush obama has been
the generals
you're the ones calling the shots yeah
you're the ones in there saying look
i've been in war i've been in
afghanistan for 20 years here's what we
need to do
who's the loudmouth general out there
talking right now it's so easy to blame
biden or so easy to blame trump and
trump did the deal and biden just went
through with the so easy why aren't the
generals it's hard it's hard for them
because they all they went all in on the
establishment to get rid of trump so
it's hard it's very hard for a guy like
mattis who i'm a big fan of it's very
hard for him right now to be like i i i
backed the wrong horse uh you know it's
very very difficult but the point is
this like who cares that you're talking
about america i agree with you yeah but
that's the presidential but this is also
when you say that who cares stuff again
like this is uh you know
because because it's in this moment
you've been so vilified in this in this
divisive political environment like this
is what i'm saying when i talk about i
don't want taxes taxes or theft and if
people are like i don't mind paying my
fair share if it means that a kid can
read and education gets better and
there's no child
how they walk when they're talking yeah
but they're with their warby parker's
like people i'm about to see easier
no it's not this is what your tax money
goes to your tax money doesn't your tax
money doesn't go to kids getting books
in schools your tax money goes to this
so until these people tell you and show
you that they can use the hours of your
life we've discussed this taxes aren't
just money money represents the hours of
your life that is eight billion hours of
american lives left behind for the enemy
to play around with and hang people from
apache freaking helicopters that's
subsidized by you and me guys that right
there high five guys we didn't we
sponsored that and we're not going to
talk about this like my question is how
long are we going to continually talk
about this to drive that point home to
the general public because there's a lot
of people in this world that don't pay
attention to politics in this way they
don't pay attention to military in this
way this type of news needs to be
continuously over and over and there
that
there's a lesson to be learned in this
and we're all discussing it right here
but until that becomes like the norm
we're we're going to do this [ __ ] again
the other lesson we learned i know we're
going to talk about we avoid i know
we're going to talk about this but the
other lesson we learned is every time
they tell you that you can't take on the
government like all these second
amendment guys we got f-16s yeah yeah
right they got everything i'm laughing
in farsi i laugh in north vietnam you're
telling me that i'll give up my guns
because why because
eric swalwell you don't have nukes yeah
what did the taliban have
don't ever
ever forget your second amendment you
know they said the taliban officially
moved up 161 spots in the strongest
military in the world
a hundred from our stuff from our stuff
161 spots
in the strongest military in the world
so that means they're like in the top 50
right now can i think about the taliban
the taliban's military after what they
just took is in the top 50 militaries in
the world right now what is their ties
and i'm just going off here like what
are their ties with the communist party
here in china
do they have any ties with that well
they have ties with pakistan and then
pakistan has ties i'm just talking i'm
just thinking in regards to like
technology and stuff like that it's a
good thought because this is this is all
a proxy because if yeah because i'm
thinking well like okay like who's
responsible for this who's responsible
for everybody's got to be responsible
for something who's last night you and i
had a conversation together right we had
a little bit of a hiccup and we were
talking to each other and like yeah you
know what my how my hair got too high by
the way yeah it's a funny story behind
me i like the hair so we're talking
we're saying hey
but the point is who who gets the
responsibility on this adam who gets the
responsibility on this
are you looking for a figurehead or well
you listen i mean
you know
everything rises and falls on leadership
who's responsible for this look i i if
you want to go the easy clear answer
biden and he's he even went out and said
look this is on me
he said this
um what should be the repercussions
well the voters will determine that well
but we can't wait that long but what i'm
asking you is
he's not getting impeached it's not like
none of that okay it's not happening so
let me ask you a question let's just say
we go there because you know republicans
are like let's impeach the guy okay fine
but let's just what you're saying yeah
but the liberals wanted to impeach trump
twice and they celebrate the first time
in history a president got impeached
twice on their resume right okay
let's and then they're saying let's
resign them and then they're saying
court martial right
how should he be held accountable to
this i'm actually curious right like
nixon resigned over what
nixon watergate watergate which was what
today watergate is like a step number
three it's like watergate is nothing
today done by both sides watergate is
very obama literally didn't got nothing
happened no question about it so did
hillary it's a very simple model but how
should he be held accountable not just
voting how should he build accountable
today because in a corporate world in a
corporate world if i run a corporation
and i accidentally cost the corporation
85 billion dollars you know what happens
to a guy like me i mean it's like the
board is going to sit down and say steve
jobs we kind of love you but dude you
are fired and we're going to bring in
the scholarly and we're going to bring
you back seven years later if you earned
the right but right what should happen
to this guy today why should why should
free enterprise have more pressure of
their job being fired in the moment but
government employees they can just sit
there and say dude no one's going to
fire me what should happen today well
that's the problem that is the very
essence of the issue with authoritarian
regimes communism socialism however you
want to call it
there is no accountability in government
we talked about it before it's not your
money it's somebody else's money and and
if you blow it you know on a micro scale
we talked about bill de blasio's wife
bill de blasio's wife made a billion
dollars a billion dollars of taxpayer
money disappeared there wasn't an
investigation there wasn't criminal
charges she got promoted she is now
handling the dissemination of the funds
so what should be done
well
by the way there's two people that look
very good right now
there's two people that look very good
right now one of them you know
the other one is jimmy carter okay how
how does jimmy carter look good right
now yes who did better him or uh biden
biden is making carter look good biden
is making carter carter sitting there
saying at least i'll be able to say i'm
not the worst
of all george bush and dick cheney are
skating by on this and i they look
biden's bad but bush and cheney need to
need to have the the spotlight shine on
him chaney especially because he's back
this time around in this camp
you know donald drumsfield your boy i
hate him hey horrible horrible horrible
human being an embarrassment to me
rumsfeld no no vice wasn't great oh i
didn't see it you did not see violence i
didn't see it you're kidding me nah
why why why why like i mean i'm uh
hollywood doesn't like a republican i
think to answer your question
genuinely i think it's going to earth
please listen folks everybody knows
adam's gonna give his i think it's a
little too early to just start dishing
out blame yes this is going not
according to plan correct okay cool i
don't think anybody likes to see what's
going on here but let's see what the
long-term ramifications of this the
bottom line is this
americans overwhelmingly did not want to
be in afghanistan let's not just like
gloss over that for years and years
already addressed that okay but for
years and years we paid zero attention
to this for years and years our military
our government was lying basically
saying everything's fine
don't worry about afghanistan we got it
all under control turns out they were
lying the entire time turns out we could
not control 75 000 taliban fighters
turns out 75 000 people fighting for
their homeland fighting for infidels
is a lot more powerful than any amount
of army that's getting paid to play well
you don't have to win you just have to
stalemate
it's how we've got the british to get
this country but stalemate for how long
20 years for 50 years 100 years
i think the bottom line is i think we
have way too many internal issues in
america to be worried about afghanistan
it sucks what's going on short term
right now but with everything that's
going on in america
you name the list of issues debt
obviously our tax system health care
homelessness the list goes on and on and
on
yeah now we're now we're worried about
the afghani people with all due respect
we've got enough voters i don't know but
this has got nothing to do with afghani
people
what what does this have to do with
afghanistan what what what part of this
issue is afghani people
what part of yeah what part of this is
afghani people
i mean you're saying yeah you're saying
let's forgive we have so many issues
here let's forget about that
you know the people afghanistan but
let's address our issues nobody
disagrees but is this an afghani people
issue
no this is an american government
spending and focus issue this is this is
this is a this is a
this is a strategic issue okay
if you hire a c-suite executive
you hire a c-suite executive because
you're expecting this person to be
competent in what areas
and they're whatever they're
specifically expected
right okay if i'm a cmo my job is to do
a great job and what just like you're a
general in the army i expect to be
competent at leading an army exactly
what level of competency did you see in
this move that took place two weeks ago
that's the question that we all have is
who's the one actually
what i'm saying to you is you're saying
we already have so many problems
this could have been prevented if the
level of competency was done in a
different way this is not a issue
that we disagree in this is an issue of
competency this is an issue of common
sense this is an issue of basic strategy
for a person that in
113 billion people have been born from
day one till today you see that
statistic of how many people have lived
there's only been 46 positions for u.s
presidents he's one of them don't you
think there needs to be a little bit
more competency when it comes down to
issues like this that's the only thing
i'm questioning we talked last night
crazy i asked gerard last night if
you're comfortable answering this you
can say it on camera i asked gerard
would you rather have hillary clinton as
a president or joe biden what'd you say
hillary clinton how long did it take for
his answer
what did you say
hillary okay now here's the question
would you rather have trump as president
today or biden
on this particular issue or every issue
in america just no just just take just
take overall competency
decision-making process would you rather
have biden or would you have trump
on this particular issue obviously biden
is failing there's other things that i
think is doing better than trump such i
don't think it's a binary option but but
i think it is though because i think
it's competency like i think i honestly
think as much as there is nowhere that
i'm gonna one day have a hillary clinton
autograph in my office
i don't seek for that but i honestly
maybe a bill maybe a bill clinton
autograph but i don't mind a bill but i
will you literally have
this is not guys this has got nothing
this has got to do to me
who's a bigger badass hillary or biden
not biden biden wasn't elected to be a
badass that's not that's the problem
that's the problem
this is a competency issue and a
leadership issue folks if you're
watching this right now if you're
watching this right now you have two
choices
you have trump i'm sorry you have biden
or hillary who do you pick and by the
way this is like an interesting crowd
right who do you pick you have a bite or
a trump issue who do you pick this is a
leadership issue
this is not about who won or who didn't
the world hated trump because trump was
pushing everyone's buttons he was the
obnoxious guy that's going out and
calling you out hey you got a big belly
hell your nose is big hey you got a big
pimple on your forehead that's trump
is that fair to say that's his style
he's going to go and call everybody and
just get under everyone's skin well he
also turned the free money spigot off
which is why they really got real and
then he put all the sanctions on
everybody he decided like he said you
know what i'm going to go from uh a
person everybody wants to be like me kid
grows that wants to be like donald trump
rappers want to be like donald trump i'm
going to go to be the most hated person
in the world by pushing everyone's
buttons he just woke up when they said
i'm gonna put your butt in china mexico
canada everybody and he had the formula
down but when it comes down to
situations like this because your top
position presidency
out of everything you and i need to do
in the job okay maybe let me ask this
back and we'll change topic because
we've got other things to get into
here's a question for you
tell me the number one quality of a
great comedian not top five the number
one you guys are in that world i have no
idea i think it's charisma
is it timing is it charisma you can you
can learn timing i think it's charisma
you can't fake it i don't know
what do you say timing and charisma you
put timing first or charisma give me one
of them i just wanna reading the room i
said charisma okay charisma what do you
say charisma for sure okay fine fair but
there's what's simple without what's the
number one quality of a person that
could win mr olympia that could win mr
olympia not be competing for mr olympia
but windmill i think i know the answer
but i'm curious what you say you
definitely have to own the crowd
okay you i mean obviously if you have
the physique i mean that's that you have
to have the physique okay so that's
number one yes you have to have genetics
you have to have the genetics is that
fair oh absolutely if you don't have it
it doesn't matter like chad nichols said
i can take everything i'm never going to
win this drawing correct you've got to
have a gift uh somebody said like a
seven times a stroll
okay let's continue what is number one
number one not top five what is the
number one quality for you to uh have a
girl go from being a girlfriend to a
wife
number one not top five
maybe a bad question for you right now
i i think uh every every woman says they
want to have a good communicator someone
who listens okay so someone wants to
ability stability would that be security
stability fair literally working on
stability he's getting stable he's moved
into his new spot i'm proud of you
what's the number one rule of becoming a
millionaire
number one save that goddamn money okay
so let's just say you save the money
right what is the number one um
duty
of being a president not top 5 not top
10 number one protect your people secure
your borders boom you got it so what i'm
trying to tell you
is everything that happens this year
nothing is above securing your people
that's number one and he's not doing it
and trump did
okay
there's presidents that did he did not
do that and that's what you get held
accountable for
that's accountability that is only thing
i'm asking for because you have to be
competent
last night i hear [ __ ] in the backyard
who has to get up and grab the gun and
go walk around damn right i have to do
it i'm the guy that's the security of
the house i don't say
well
let me send my 79 year old dad to go see
jimbo yeah let me go see what's going on
okay there's a big ass possum on
steroids sitting outside like massive
benching three plates
i'm like freaking this guy could compete
for possums
so he's in the backyard
but the point is the point is competency
security a husband a man provides
security competency for the family a
president has to give us confidence that
if somebody comes and invades us or does
something to us that person is going to
put the freaking
a level of fear in the other person to
say dude i'm pulling out i'm kicking
back listen i got you i'm going to give
you a [ __ ] back it sounds like you agree
with joe benano's book a little bit we
need a head of a family is that the idea
you're going back to mafia you're
watching way too much
[Music]
made the same argument we just need one
guy he takes care of everybody it's like
a father maybe you'd say a boss i don't
think it's just one guy i just think
like to me when you think about somebody
where you're gonna say okay like right
now you look at candidates as an
ex-president you got to think about
somebody that's going to be protecting
the nation you have to think about
somebody that's going to protect them i
think and make other people think twice
when they want to screw with america i
mean that's that's i think more than
anything else guys we as citizens have
to look at this and say this central
planning can never work because this is
what's always going to happen this idea
that some government some altruistic
government is going to come and they're
going to take care of everything they
can't figure anything out all it takes
is one batch of peter principle and
ruins the entire empire man get rid of
imperialism because it's impossible and
it's not profitable except for very few
people at the top capitalism is the way
not imperialism and also guys the
centralized stuff and now they're going
to pivot to climate change they're
pivoting on the crime of crisis they're
making canada talk about what happened
in canada oh it's all over it's
australia new zealand canada where uh
trudeau came out and said we're gonna
we're going to apply the lessons learned
from this war on covid in the war
against the climate crisis and all of
our environmental crisis and inequity
and and so uh social justice and i was
like wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
the lessons learned like in new york
right now today you know i love talking
about my my favorite home soviet block
new york city right the the the great uh
hugo new york
it's
you have
to show your papers
you have to show your papers you have to
show yourself your paper
where's your paper so you cannot get
into the bodega today yeah it's it's you
can't eat groceries without showing now
here's what's in asinine about this if
you have a covid vaccine
you can still be positive coven positive
and go eat in a restaurant but it's okay
you you you've got your ouchie so no big
deal but if you if you test negative all
right like cole beasley if you test
negative and you've been exposed to
somebody all right who who did a test
but they but they complied it's okay
they can feed their children did you see
the article i sent yesterday
um i don't even know if we want to get
into it yeah with our phds
yes
you know what we should care more about
the channel than anyone
that anyone hears opinions you know what
[ __ ] let's get the channel taken down
who needs the channel at this point
[ __ ] hey oh you're crazy
but but let me ask you this it was a
great article
if anybody wants to get this article
send me a tweet
patrick david maybe later on today i'll
share the article with you it's a very
interesting article sent to us by one of
our good friends here so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]